this is a production of cornell
university
well good afternoon everybody and uh
thanks for the introductions and really
want to thank steve and everybody else
for being so nimble and converting this
to a virtual event so i can do this from
my own office of course
it would be great to see you all in
person
but hopefully next year we can have the
opportunity
so today we'll be talking about rodent
management for agricultural producers
and we are going to jump right in
to the content of why
so
if you're attending this talk today i'm
guessing that you have or have had a
problem with rodents in the past
it's estimated that each year they cause
millions of dollars in damage to
agricultural production and specifically
with losses
to crops
and they cause a variety of damage types
whether it's in a building or
some type of
facility where you're living or where
your animals are being housed so i'm
just going to run through some of these
and talk about why the need for control
is so important
rodents have a propensity to gnaw on
wires it's thought that wires mimic
things like vines and twigs in their
natural
environments and they think there may be
insects or liquid that would come from
those twigs and provide them nourishment
so you can see
in this picture here this is a wire that
has been chewed by a rat and that can
lead to equipment failures if it's on a
tractor or an engine of some type of
machinery
if it's in a structure it can actually
lead to a fire
and in
commercial buildings it's estimated that
25
of fires of unknown origin are caused by
rodents gnawing on wires in walls
so certainly there there's structural
damage that can occur from rodent damage
they'll also chew
to access their resources whether that's
to find a harborage or nesting site
to access water or to be closer to a
food or heat source
and so in
these two images that you see on the
left here um let me see if i can get the
little laser pointer there we go
you see this hole that was chewed into
an old school chicken coop and you see
the result on the inside here where rats
were coming in
and feeding on the grains
prepared here for the chickens also
drinking the water and harassing these
animals
um and in some settings when you know
feed conversion is extremely important
if you have all these holes caused by
rodents it's gonna decrease the
temperature and going to affect
how your animals are doing in that
environment so it's not just the
structure but also influence impacts on
the animals as well
some of the rodents that we'll talk
about today are going to burrow in the
soil and that includes our groundhogs
and rats and this can lead to cave-in
issues where the soil then collapses on
top of itself
if there if you're running a tractor
over that there could be damage to the
machinery if you're walking over that
there could be damage to you
um
predation as we mentioned small birds
eggs and other animals may be bitten as
well so
rats can be
you know probing
in their behavior if they come upon a
sleeping animal and think there may be a
food source there they may bite and
cause issues and injury to those animals
and of course the the main concern that
we have is contamination of food
feed and product so this all translates
to rodents being an extremely economic
pest
when we think about the pathogens that
rodents carry there are two main ways
that they are transmitting these to
people
the first is direct transmission and
this occurs when there is as you might
assume direct contact between
the person pet or livestock and the
rodent or the evidence they leave behind
so direct contact with feces and urine
can actually lead to
transmission of pathogens
as well as
bites
so you know i have these two images
below to represent two common things
that can occur
with direct transmission um
here's a person holding dead rodents
obviously this is an older photo
but people capture and kill rodents all
the time they may not wear gloves when
they do this
and especially this time of year when
our hands are dry and cracked
there may be exposure to our blood
system and so that's one way that we can
directly be exposed to rodent pathogens
um
if you've heard of hantavirus this is a
pathogen carried by
the field mice the white-footed mouse
and deer mouse and it's shed in their
feces
when those feces dry if someone comes in
to clean them up by using a broom or
brushing them those
virus particles can be aerosolized and
breathed in through our nose where they
contact our mucous membranes and that's
how we're exposed to hantavirus so
just being around their evidence can
cause us to
have direct exposure to their pathogens
indirect transmission occurs when
there's some sort of vector or
ectoparasite involved and this includes
fleas ticks lice and mites
if you're actively managing rodents on
your property and you kill a rat that
has a flea on it that flea is going to
look for another host and if it's
carrying a pathogen when it finds that
other host it can transmit it to you or
your pets or livestock
so in general there's a few
circumstances where these
risks of exposure are highest and that
would be if you're dealing with rodents
in confined spaces like this attic space
these are all droppings up there and if
someone was to try and clean them out
they could potentially be exposed if
they're not taking the proper
precautions
um removing feces handling carcasses and
handling traps that have been
inundated with feces and urine
so
you know that's the phase of this
presentation where i'm trying to scare
you because i want you to take rodent
issues seriously it's not just oh that's
a rat that's a mouse
they could potentially be carrying
pathogens that affect your health and
the health of your pets and livestock
so because of um the challenges that
rodents represent and some
really
recent and important topics that dan
will cover
um we wanted to find out more about how
people and specifically farmers in new
york state are managing rodent
populations
with the help of dan and my supervisor
jody ganglov kaufman we developed a
survey with nine questions on rodent
issues and management practices
this was distributed by a number of
folks at cornell and local offices and
if anybody on the call today
received this survey and filled it out
we certainly thank you for your
participation
we had a total of 141 responses to a
digital survey and we have not received
any paper versions back
so i'm just going to run through some of
those results and queue up dan to talk
about
some of the issues and then we'll talk
about eroding we'll
go through a rodent management program
so when asked which rodents have you
ever seen the need to control anywhere
on your farm
the number one pest that people
identified was mice
this wasn't broken down to the different
species of mice that we have that can be
a pest
in and around structures
here we have represented the field mouse
or the
deer mouse and white footed mouse
we also have house mice which are a
different species
and so
we're lumping all these critters
together
groundhogs and woodchucks were second
and rats were third and then followed by
all these other critters that are
considered to be wildlife
in the eyes of new york state
rodents are
considered a problem in crop production
areas so the highest response rate was
for
that location
but rodents are a problem for farmers
and agricultural producers in any number
of locations
we didn't ask a question in the survey
of what type of commodity do you produce
certainly if we knew that there there
may be some reasons why um there's
different you know animal housing is a
high percentage that could be because
most of the people that receive the
survey have animals um we're not sure
but in any case you know the areas that
people are most concerned are where your
crops are being grown
so we don't want to see any damage to
those commodities
um an interesting one that wasn't listed
on the survey but but people came back
and said is an issue were the maple
syrup lines and again
these are very similar in
size and shape to wires and so rodents
again may perceive that there's some
sort of resource within these maple
syrup lines which in fact there is
there's a
readily available liquid for them to
drink
what methods are used to manage rodent
pests and so this is what we kind of
expected was that
rodenticide baits would be the number
one
reported
technique used to manage rats and mice
and other rodents available on the farm
snap traps came in second and then you
can you know see through some of these
other
techniques that are available as part of
a rodent management program but may not
be used
very extensively on new york state farms
so encouraging wildlife
cats
glue boards exclusion etc and we'll talk
about some of these as we talk about
developing our own rodent management
program
some alternative options that people
presented so um
the use of dogs to hunt
rodents on the farm
shooting rodents and live trapping were
also commonly reported in the survey
these are just listed for the purpose of
indicating what people responded
some of these techniques that are
included here have efficacy data but
others do not so
again we'll look at those later on
who implements the methods used to
manage rodents on farms so
in most cases that is falling to the
person who responded to the survey the
owner themselves or their immediate
family in some cases that's farm staff
in very few cases that is
hired pest control business
and
the instances where that takes place is
probably a large production where
they have the resources to hire an
outside contractor for that problem
some of the other
you know people that were providing pest
management for rodents on farms were
farm partners nuisance people with a
nuisance license or ipm extension
which of the following
applicator certifications do you or your
staff hold
so for this question we really wanted to
know um what level of education are
people receiving about the
the different techniques used to manage
rodents and then what license categories
do they have
when we listed all of these categories
that could have some
education about rodent management or
just in general about pesticide
management
we found that most respondents did not
have any
certification
and so we have um listed here the
different categories where people did
have a license
have you or others on your farm received
any trading on rodent management
and again um
you know very few
people have received formal training and
this relates back to our previous
question about certification um but most
respondents have not received any formal
training
and so this is um concerning to me as an
educator about pesticide management and
um
particularly rodent management um
rodents as we'll see today are extremely
complex animals and managing them
requires an understanding of their
biology
if we go to the store
whether it's tractor supply or any other
big box store we can buy a huge variety
of products with no education on how to
use them and
so there's a good potential here that
people are misusing products um in their
management of rodents
um and so lastly we asked what sources
of information would you use to learn
about rodent management and the
overwhelming um or the highest response
was for the internet so people are
searching online to find information
about rodent management
and we know that
there's a lot of misinformation
available on the internet um when i give
my pest identification seminars i i love
pulling up a google page and searching
for a particular pest and seeing
all the other things that come up
so things are
miscategorized there's information that
hasn't been vetted and so there's
certainly
concern when we see that the internet is
the number one resource for managing
rodent pest problems
some of these others are good sources so
county extension offices
that information is usually vetted
cornell university faculty and programs
might be vetted but word of mouth and
farm supply store
again if you're not an expert in rodent
management or pesticide use you may not
know the nuances of controlling that
particular organism so hopefully today
we'll probably provide some insights
we did ask open-ended questions about
biggest concerns and a lot of these
related to damage to product
physical damage
pathogens and then the challenges of
managing rodents with
you know different restrictions so if
they have an organic production or
if the problem is coming from a neighbor
how is that problem managed
and then um we asked for any additional
questions that people may have about
rodent management and a lot of them were
general questions about how to
effectively
manage those rodents so again that's
kind of the reason why we wanted to
bring this presentation today is to get
some of this general information out
there and create new opportunities to
reach
the agricultural sector
when we
ask for concerns that people may have
about rodent management these in
particular really stood out to me
because there was a continuum of
topics
from
people want to manage rodents in
non-lethal ways so they want to
[Music]
not harm them in
ways that are unethical
all the way to people wanting to use the
most effective and most dangerous poison
possible
um to managing rodents on the farm so
there's a continuum here and
really highlights an opportunity for us
to deliver effective education and
outreach
so just in summary and then i'll turn it
over to dan
rodent management on new york farms
is a problem because rodents are found
in areas of production
of storage and other locations where
product is damaged
farm farmers and
owners are the ones that perform rodent
management 76 percent of the time 60
percent of farmers are using
rodenticides to manage pests
56 do not have any sort of applicator
license and 89 indicate that they have
not received training on roading control
so with that um i will mute and turn it
over to dan
okay thanks matt
so futuristic pointed out the frequency
of rodent problems on farms potential
damage they can cause
and the lack of formal training in the
ag community all point to a need for the
outreach matinee are trying to
generate today
the big question is why now
you know why did we want to get this on
the agenda this year
so next map
and
what we found is recent reports
show that 80 to 100 of raptors you know
birds of prey
brought to wildlife disease experts
showed traces of rodenticides in their
systems
often being the cause of death and this
has been an ongoing problem
with birds of prey as well as mammals
that prey on rodents
next
okay
and this has led california to ban most
uses of representation i believe this is
just in the last year they first tried
to take rodenticides out of the hands of
homeowners by making them all restricted
use
but
the frequency of the currents of
you know poisoning and birds of prey and
other mammals non-target organisms
didn't lessen at all
so they increased the ban to include
most uses especially for structural pest
control those juices are now gone in
california
but while egg use is still allowed
a lot of rodent experts believe that the
problem might really be laying out in
the agricultural community because
that's where the birds of prey and the
mammals who are being
poisoned by rodenticides tend to live
so it's possible that in a couple years
california will say well
we're still not seeing any decrease in
the non-targeted poisoning so we're just
going to ban all uses including ag
and
you know california often leads in these
sorts of things so new york might file
epa might follow
and so we want to get the
you know the outreach and training out
to you
to prevent two problems one is
you know prevent non-target poisoning
and the other is to prevent the loss of
these tools if you know if you need them
to control erosions on your farm you
want them to still be available
next please
and then there's a problem that alluded
to about
you know survey showing a lot of people
looking at the internet for
solutions
um
there's a lot of misinformation on the
internet a lot of sites talking about
using mothballs to repel rodents
and there's three main problems with
this the you know one is illegal it's
off labeled use
um
i do know after being in this business
for 30 years a lot of people aren't
going to care about that
what they should care about is they'll
be completely ineffective
uh mothballs are only meant to work in
small combined spaces and then one
against insects
if you're sprinkling them you know in a
barn or
at the entrance to a burrow
it's not going to be effective at all
against rodents
the other problem is when they are put
out in the open they become attractive
to pets and livestock if they eat them
they're very dangerous when ingested and
even kids will see these flakes or
mothballs lying around and think they're
candy
and you look at poison control there is
a lot of exposure among kids to muffle
so
don't use them they're ineffective and
they're dangerous to pets
livestock and your kids
next
and there's live interest out there
about using feral cats as a solution i
mean chicago even released a thousand
cats into the city's streets to try to
deal with their rat problem
and the problem with that next map is
that cats really aren't very good at
rodent control especially rats
if you want to have fun go on google and
just search for a cat or rat chase's cat
you'll find a very
broad selection of humorous videos to
watch
here in new york a study was done
uh
looking at cats whether or not they can
control rodent populations what they
found was
that you indeed see fewer rats when you
introduce cats into the environment
but you're not controlling the rat
population at all they're just going
undercover the populations aren't going
down the damage isn't being lessened
they're just hiding from the cats so
people think oh look it's working i've
seen much you know many fewer rats since
i put cats into the area
but you haven't dealt with the problem
at all
next
and cats don't really fix the problem of
burns being killed by rotten control
mayors either
outdoor cats literally kill
billions of birds a year
and you know if they were just going
after the starlings or the the pigeons
are causing a problem on your farm
that'd be one thing
uh but they're targeting song groups
um
which are actually very beneficial
organs organisms they eat a lot of
insects uh some of you might have wood
lots to rely on for additional income
you know harvested timber on occasion
and sog birds strongholds have been
shown to be very
crucial to healthy forests by eating the
insect pests in forests
so
we want to preserve those birds as well
next
so if all these concerns and things
massive as talked about and you know
pending legislation that could happen
we want to provide the outreach to
provide you
with science-based information and how
to reduce the impact of rodents
both with respect to your ag
productivity and finances but also
protect you
and farm animals from disease that
rodents can carry
it's not just on farm
if rodent droppings get into grain
that's shipped downstream
that can cause probably salmonella and
all sorts of problems
uh
people eventually eating food products
made from that grain
so we want to minimize non-target
exposure to
rodenticizing the harmonic causes
and that will do two things so one
prevent non-target injury which nobody
wants but also help keep rodenticides in
the toolbox in your ipm program
for effectively managing rodents
um
next slide now
so before i turn it back over to matt to
talk about effective road management
um i just want to cover the legality of
using or genocides on the farm
if you're using general use pesticide
downsides the only time you need to be
certified on the farm is using them in
farm work or housing and that's because
new york state regulations actually
require you to be certified to apply any
pesticide
in someone else's living space okay you
can use generous pesticides all you want
in your own home
over someone else's living that's a
different matter
with restricted use for genocides
any of your private
applicator certifications will cover
that use
except around
farm equipment storage or in any
residence either yours or farm workers
in which case you would need
commercial certification
so keep that in mind as
matt now talks about
the overall process of managing rodents
on farms
great
well thanks dan um so yeah so the next
uh phase here is that we're just gonna
walk through a rodent management plan
and talk about all the different
components that we currently have
for managing rodents on the farm so
the first
step is going to be our inspection
and followed by identification of the
target pest
and then we're going to reduce the
populations first with short-term
management plans that quickly eliminate
the population and then long-term
pest reduction which addresses the
environmental conditions that support
those pests
monitoring and evaluation
so
uh typically when i provide a
presentation on rodent management i
spend about 60
of that presentation on the inspection
process
and this is because um the inspection is
so critical to developing a rodent
management plan
um it's key to finding out where the
pest problems are located and the extent
of that problem
defining the structural deficiencies so
they're the ways that they come in
and the ways that they use the
environment identifying which pest
species is present
any sanitation or water issues that
provide nourishment for them
establishing the treatment method
and specifically determining what
material to use and where
and when it comes to rodent inspections
there's always the recommendation of
performing these at dusk or just before
dawn because that's when rodents are
most active so if we can actually
observe the critters
when they're doing
their forging or
performing damage
it really helps us understand the best
places to put our management equipment
so in terms of
our inspection and this is why it's such
a huge part of a presentation we're
looking for
not just the rodent evidence the things
that rodents leave behind but also the
the environmental conditions that are
attractive to them that make them want
to be in that location
so the first thing um you know
recognizing the evidence i will say
don't be fooled by the stool
there's a lot of things out there that
can be easily confused with rodent
droppings
and so this first one on the top left is
about the same size shape and color as
rodent droppings
but in fact these are fly pupil cases
if you've ever
killed a rodent with a rodenticide
and that rodent is in an inaccessible
location
you would have noticed that from the
smell
and that smell is disgusting to us but
highly attractive to decomposers like
blow flies and other types of flies
the flies will lay their eggs on that
carcass develop into
mature larvae and then crawl away from
that food source and that is when this
stage would be observed so
there's times when a rodent problem can
result in these fly pupil cases ending
up in extremely weird places
so it's important to be able to
distinguish them and recognize them
rodent poop is distinguished from other
types of droppings that could be found
by having a pointed end
and then also hair mixed in
so rodents are groomers they are
constantly licking themselves to clean
off anything that gets on their fur
and in that process they will ingest
some of that hair you can see it come
out the other end in this picture
those are mouse droppings obviously the
large droppings up here on the right are
rat droppings and these are all to scale
the third type of dropping that
sometimes
gets confused with rodent droppings
especially in buildings but certainly
in swine production and other types of
livestock
rearing are cockroach droppings
these are droppings from an american
cockroach they're about the same size
and shape as mouse droppings
but whereas rodent droppings have
pointed ends these typically have blunt
ends
and they will have these vertical lines
on them that are formed by the internal
structures on the cockroach so
easy to distinguish when you look close
but most people don't want to take that
close of a look at poop
okay
so some of the other evidence that we
have are going to be footprints
rats will leave whole footprints in
dirt in dust so in a lot of settings
where
people are not active there could be
collections of dust and it'll be very
easy to see these footprints
rats will also leave a tail drag
especially in large adult rats so you
can
distinguish which pest is present from
those
whereas mice
it's almost like they're running on
their toes and they leave these sort of
little pock marks
we have measurements there but it's very
easy to distinguish those pests
um we can actually distinguish which
rodent pest we have from the size of the
non-marks that are left behind
and
we will take a look
at an example of why this is important
so for a pair of teeth if we broke out
our little ruler and we found that they
measure one to two millimeters we're
looking at a mouse problem
if a pair of teeth measures three and a
half to four millimeters then we are
dealing with rats
um rodents are mammals just like us and
we have sebaceous glands associated with
our hairs
rodents have the same and they are
constantly producing these oils that
coat their furs
as they walk over or through the same
path time and again they will actually
deposit those
oils leaving what's known as a sebum
trail
so this is inside a building you can see
where the heavy mouse population was
running under a door and going into this
little hole here at the bottom
but those same oils can be detected
outdoors
this is next to a rock wall where there
was a rat
infestation and as the rats ran out to
find their food source they were
depositing those oils so
sebum trails are helpful in
determining where rodents are moving
and then of course for
rats and
groundhogs like we said we said earlier
they will create these burrows that are
very easy to distinguish and find out in
our environments
i suppose i didn't include this picture
here so the reason that it becomes
really important to distinguish between
rats and mice in some cases if we aren't
seeing
the critter that's causing the evidence
and we haven't found any droppings
if we put out bait and we measure the
teeth marks on that bait we can
determine which type of trap we need to
use in order to catch those rodents
otherwise
you know we may think that we have rats
or we may think we're dealing with mice
and put out the wrong device
and rat devices are too slow and clunky
to catch mice and mouse traps are too
small to do anything to a rat so we need
to make sure we're selecting the
appropriate piece of equipment
we do have these forms available on our
website
and i can share that link at the end of
today's presentation
to
help you collect the information that
may be pertinent
this is on our pest exclusion page and
would help you collect information about
where rodent activity is found
what type of evidence is present and
what the recommendations would be to
implement a management program
so once we
perform our inspection we want to
identify the pest as we said there are
keys that are out there
to help you differentiate the various
pests that may be found on a farm
but knowing which pest is going to
really help you
figure out the management strategy
because pest identification informs
where the nest sites are found
when that
organism is active seasonally what their
preferred food sources are what their
reproductive capacity is and even their
foraging habits
so i like to give this example that
accurate identification is
essential
and the target pest will influence our
management plan
here we have
two different species of mice
one of them
is the house mouse
and house mice are permanent residents
inside structures if they're introduced
to a grain bin they're going to stay
there their entire life they don't need
to forage for water they can
metabolize the grains and get enough
nourishment from that
and so if we know that they're staying
in that one location for their entire
life we know that our priority for
managing them is going to be trapping
them on the inside
and doing some sort of
exclusion to prevent them from moving to
different areas with inside that
structure
on the other hand our paramiscus species
our
white-footed mouse and our deer
deer mice
they are seasonal visitors so they spend
most of their year outdoors but in the
fall through spring they come indoors
they will nest and reproduce
and so if we are catching or observing
this mouse inside it means that there's
an opportunity for us to seal them out
so they can't come in
so again you know we provide the
identification chart that'll help you
figure out which pests you have so that
we can implement a pest reduction plan
without a comprehensive plan what ends
up happening is that we just harvest
individuals from the population we don't
manage or eliminate that
infestation so we're going to talk about
all of these different approaches to
rodent management and then integrating
them so that we have an effective
management plan
we'll talk about trapping the use of
rodenticide baits and
asphyxiation with burrow treatments
so based on our survey we know that a
lot of
agricultural producers in new york state
are using rodenticide baits
realistically it's the most economic
approach because we can purchase a bait
put it in a bait station put it outside
and hope for the best right we don't
have to reset anything we just have to
make sure that there's an ample supply
of bait of course there are risks
associated with the use of these baits
dan highlighted a lot of these for
wildlife
but also for non-target effects
including our pets and
small children would be interested in
some of these candy looking
baits
they come in a variety of sizes shapes
consistencies textures ingredients and
colors and all for different reasons
so different um formulations have
different uses and different use
restrictions
so even if you are buying contract block
which is
a very common
bait used in a lot of different settings
there's pelletized bait there's
block baits there's soft bait packets
and each of these can be used in
different ways requiring that we look
very closely at the label
so pelletized baits for example can be
put into a burrow
but if those pelletized baits are
purchased in these place packs you
cannot open that place pack and put it
in the burrow
that's a restriction on the label and so
we have to follow that
to make sure that we are using these
products safely
in terms of following that label and
applications the one that i really
wanted to highlight was the use of
tamper-resistant bait stations
and
this came from our survey large chunk
bait is useless small pellets work the
work the best modern bait stations are
useless milk jugs with holes work very
well
so this is um you know someone's
approach to road management they don't
think that the these bait stations are
effective and what i would contend is
that the placement of these devices it's
what's really essential to make them
effective
if we put them in the correct location
based on our inspection we can ensure
that rodents are
most likely to visit the device and feed
on the bait in a way that is safe and
protecting the
people pets and livestock around
so
for
outdoor above ground applications we are
required to use a tamper resistant bait
station
[Music]
the requirement to do so is
falls on the applicator so whoever's
putting out the bait and not be more
hydrating
if they're an environment that doesn't
have much protein they would be
attracted to that as well
and then there's options for us to not
use a bait at all if we find
a runway that has lots of droppings or
sebum trail we can actually place a trap
without setting any bait on it at all
the rodents will just run over that that
location
the thing that we don't want to do is
over bait a trap
in this bottom right image you see a lot
of nutella which in my opinion is a
horrible waste because nutella is
delicious
and if we put too much bait on that
paddle it actually reduces the efficacy
of that trap so we want to make sure
that we're putting bait just in the well
that is found right here at the base of
the trap
we want to make sure that we're placing
traps based on our assessment i think
this is the the biggest part of the
inspection is that we're looking for the
rodent evidence so that we can place
devices where they're active
this can include overhead
locations like pipes these pipes are
running in a garage and you can see the
the mouse droppings overhead
if we affix the trap to that location we
have a much better
chance of catching a rodent than if we
put them on the ground where it's
convenient for us to service the device
another technique that can be used to
enhance our capture is if we place
runway traps in pairs
rodents may be running along and see a
trap ahead of them they'll take a leap
and if you have a another trap that's in
line with the first trap they will land
on that second device so spacing them a
couple inches apart can can help us
capture more rodents
i mentioned asphyxiation so there are
products that are available that use
carbon monoxide and carbon dioxide gas
rat ice is one product that is
registered and uses um
carbon dioxide gas it's a little bit
difficult to get this product in areas
outside of metropolitan locations
but the way this works is that you put
carbon dioxide or dry ice into the wrap
burrow and you close all the burrow
openings
the carbon dioxide
um you know sort of falls down because
it's heavier than air and it goes to the
lowest part of the burrow and it ends up
suffocating the rodents
it's considered a
less painful death than some of the
other techniques that we use and there
are certainly advantages to to doing
these types of burrow treatments
we mentioned earlier that ectoparasites
can jump off a dead rodent and look for
another host whether that's you or a pet
and if we are confining the rodents to
their burrow system then we're less
likely to encounter those ectoparasites
and any pathogens that are carried by
the rodent
there's also
devices like the boro rx machine that
uses carbon monoxide
and you can purchase this to inject into
rodent burrows including groundhogs
and
a new
inert gas injection system that
would also be similar where it injects
the active ingredient into the burrows
as dan
mentioned earlier there is a lack of
efficacy or scientific support for some
management approaches and those include
the repellents
a lot of companies want to try and sell
a secondary
plant metabolite as a rodent repellent
things like cedarwood oil
peppermint oil but there's just not
enough scientific evidence to support
their use
if it comes down to
eating food or being disgusted by a
smell i think rodents would choose to
eat the food and survive so
these may be useful in some settings but
not really an effective management
strategy
the use of sonic emitters has been
promoted here's you know a great
advertisement here it shows this emitter
is actually going to kill the rodents
that's the expectation
the reality out of a research study
looking at these devices shows a mouse
climbing up and actually sitting on top
of one of them so
how effective they are um if the mass is
sitting on top of it again the choice
between food and
a sound that's annoying you're going to
choose food
and again predators as dan said you know
sometimes we think that our our cats are
actually reducing the population but may
cause them to be more cryptic
the the way that we're going to
effectively eliminate a problem and
prevent them coming back is our
long-term pest reduction strategies this
includes sanitation to remove things
like clutter
clutter can provide harborage for rats
and mice um this is you know typical
setting on a farm there's old equipment
there's old
items that just get left and forgotten
and so these may provide harborage for
rodents to burrow and go undetected
but sanitation is the biggest issue so
if there is a food source readily
available to rodents and we can't
prevent them from accessing that their
populations are going to continuously
come back so anything that we can do to
remove those food sources from them is
going to help us in our management plan
one of the techniques that we try to
promote in the pest management industry
is
pest exclusion the philosophy here is
why let them enter your facility and
hopefully
trap them with a trap or have them feed
on a bait station when we could just
seal them out
so we have some resources on our website
that i'll share about
pest exclusion and the different
materials that are available to keep
pests out of structures
when we are thinking about exclusion it
really comes down to the opening size
that permits the different pests
we're not going to see something like a
groundhog come inside but we will
certainly see mice and rats
and they enter through openings that
permit their skull
so for mice
if a gap under a door is a quarter of an
inch they can fit their skull and then
wiggle the rest of their body underneath
their skull is a little bit wider than
it is tall and so for a mouse to get
into a round opening or a vertical
opening it has to be
at least 3 8 of an inch wide
and for rats obviously they're bigger
animals so you can see the larger sizes
for a gap and opening
what we want to keep in mind is that um
not all products that are used on you
know structures are going to be
effective at keeping out rodents so we
may go to a big box store and purchase a
weather strip to
think that we're going to keep rodents
out but they can easily chew through
these in one night
we may have seen that image earlier on
with the hole in the building we may
think we'll just fill that up with some
expanding foam and
you know that'll help our temperature
retention
but rodents can easily chew through that
and actually
may use expanding foam as a nesting
material so you're actually helping them
when you use that product so we want to
make sure that the materials we select
for pest exclusion are pest proof
so some of those recommendations are
here
if the opening is
one inch or less we want we might want
to consider metal mesh fibers
this is not steel wool
this is stainless steel metal mesh it's
a specific product that's sold for
rodent exclusion
if we just use steel wool or brillo that
will rust and break down over time and
provide that entry point still to
rodents
we may use elastomeric sealants which
are like caulks but they do not pull
away from the sides of the surfaces
they're attached to
or in situations like this where there's
a pipe going through an opening we can
use something called an escutcheon plate
to
affix to the structure and prevent them
from
getting around that pipe
when openings are larger or at doors we
can use hardware cloth
it works out great that
half inch hardware cloth is the right
size to exclude rats and quarter inch
hardware cloth is the right size to
exclude mice so we can use those
products to
cover holes and prevent them from
getting inside
if you're dealing with rats it's really
important that you affix that properly
to the structure just stapling it on or
even just using a screw is not effective
we need screws and washers to really
hold it down because rats if they get an
edge they can pull off
that that
hardware cloth of course we have um
rodent-proof door sweeps that are
available and then if those openings are
larger than four inches um we need to do
some real construction whether it's uh
masonry masonry work um sheet metal
bending or carpentry
rodents can easily burrow under
structures and so one of the things that
we can consider is a vegetation free
zone where we're just putting a layer of
one-inch diameter stone that is not
impervious to rodents but they're less
likely to burrow into that substrate
and monitoring so we want to track our
pest populations over time to make sure
that we are having an impact on their
numbers
this can be done with trap capture or
looking at those active rodent signs
over time are there fewer droppings
are there no activity
in terms of new sebum trails and things
like that
one way to do this for rats is to
look at their burrows and either
collapse them just step on them or fill
them with something
if they are opened up again we know that
they remain active and so we need to
continue our management approach
and then finally we want to evaluate our
program to determine if
if we've been effective
did we achieve our goals of reducing the
population and how can we improve our
rodent management program
we want to keep in mind that rodent
problems are unique depending on your
particular situation and so
because they're unique they often
require unique solutions to address
their populations
so as i mentioned
we have a number of resources on our
website the new york state ipm program
i will share some of these links in the
chat before we leave today but we have a
rats and mouse page and we also have a
pest exclusion page that has
a really good section on the right hand
side here about material selection to
help you figure out which products are
going to be effective at
preventing rats and mice from getting
into your structures
we also have a
youtube
playlist that's all about rodents and
this includes a couple videos on setting
traps effectively and what types of
traps to use
and if you just are interested in
rodents in general we have a whole
flicker gallery of
rodent problems especially in
more urban settings
and with that um if there are any
questions i'm happy to take them at this
time thank you for your attention
i wanted to mention too that um
on march 23rd there'll be a
rodent and wildlife management on the
farm session
hosted by the eastern
horticultural and agriculture
cooperative extension group so i'll put
that link in the chat if you're
interested in registering for that as
well
we have a question can you put in the
link to the youtube videos
yes so i'm going to put in a whole slew
of links here hopefully it's not
overwhelming um
they're all labeled um the youtube one
is towards the bottom
how many cases of antivirus are there in
the state is this virus prevalent around
here
good question so i i would have to look
up the
statistics on hunt virus prevalence it
is
definitely found in new york state there
have been
within the last couple years i know of
several cases on long island so you may
not even think about
more
suburban areas as having haunt virus
issues but there have been cases
fatal cases of hantavirus pulmonary
syndrome on long island
so it is it is present in new york state
[Music]
it is much more prevalent in
the western united states but it is here
okay
okay there's a question about
actually bird exclusion from rafters in
the barn
yeah bird exclusion is a whole separate
field they have um different
and really kind of cool products that
they use from netting to keep you know
across below the rafters to keep them
from even going up there they have
spikes and shock tracks and
gels and all kinds of products
that would be used
to prevent access to the area and also
deter them from
landing and roosting on that area
we don't have any resources available on
that topic on our website but certainly
if you wanted to reach out to me
um i can get you some of those resources
okay i might put a couple of companies
that i'm aware of in the chat just so
people can see it and then um cara's
question was
curious about rodenticides of reduced
risk of secondary poisoning
or are arm realistic
yes so i believe the only active
ingredient that is omri listed is the
cholecalciferol
and that's a
rodenicide
um
made of vitamin d
and
so
it's
i want to make clear that it's still a
rodenticide it still kills rodents
um
but it doesn't have the risks of
secondary anticoagulant rodenticide
poisoning because it doesn't easily
transfer to other
animals
so there are products that are
less likely to have impacts on wildlife
but they're still rodenticides and they
still
you know target mammals so they can have
um impacts if directly ingested by other
organisms
and i don't know any um
trade names of products with
cholecalciferol
okay i think that brings us right to the
end of the session here
i'll just jump on here and thank both
dan and matt for
what i thought was a really fascinating
presentation and one that i haven't
really
sat through before
but i learned an awful lot today so i
really appreciate that
uh the expo will continue tomorrow
tomorrow we have uh two sessions focused
on labor one on um dealing with h2a
audits and one
and the other dealing with um
sort of interacting with your employees
and then we also have a session
which will include pesticide credits
that will be focused on the lanternfly
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu